all right now as it's not suggested we
need to sort at this period okay so what
I want you to do is you have your book
there you have your book there we're
gonna write something down for a second
okay cuz X what is the period and you
can see it on here if you're gonna
reading it what's the period of motion
how long does it take to go through one
cycle up and then down or down and then
off I should say how many seconds just
regular cause X how longs it take okay
so if we were talking in degrees
I'd say 360 degrees I'm not talking
angles here I'm trying to make this a
time axis right so in radians I'd say
that it'd be 2pi seconds right now I
don't want it to be 2pi seconds so we
want to adjust this period and we're
gonna we can do it in a couple of ways
right so I'm gonna give a couple of
suggestions um we just saw putting a
number at the front here right that
changed it vertically that was good but
I want to change things horizontally
that's the period right so if for
example I track the two at the front
there cos 2x don't don't put it just yet
what do you predict would happen what
would be the period the time that it
takes to go through one cycle twenty
seamer is it going to double is it going
to half which one well we have this
graph sitting in front of us that's
magically magically dynamic go ahead put
the two in there oh it's going faster
isn't it so the period is halved okay
which means from 2 pi seconds it's gonna
be now pi seconds that's um that's a
wild ride okay so I I don't like roller
coasters regularly I definitely would
not like this ferris wheel okay so
that's going faster we don't want to get
faster do we weren't to go slower so how
should I just rethink it done okay if I
divided by 2 so X on to this would this
would go slow right it wasn't time
having the time it would double the time
so what would the time be for this
ah okay all right so you're a couple
steps ahead will will come to your point
in a second I don't we should sort this
out first right
we've already realized that if we want
to slow down the motion rather than make
it faster then we should divide rather
than multiply so I'm gonna have 4pi
seconds here do you agree that's better
what's 4 times pi it's like 12 13 ish
right so that's an improvement
I don't want for five seconds I want 90
seconds and also please notice there's
no PI's in this right how do I get rid
of the pie that pies gross it's annoying
how do I get rid of it what you have to
think for a second I'm gonna I'm gonna
hit pause you can see how we can adjust
the period here you've seen how we made
it faster you saw how I made it slower
I'm gonna give you a minute or two to
look with the person next to you and
you're welcome to play you've got to the
technology in front of you before mrs.
Lee's and I show you the answer do you
have enough knowledge and like I said
have a fiddle to try and work out how we
should adjust to get the right period
that we're actually after have a think
some people are getting there some
people still struggling along so let me
try and help you out okay can I draw
your attention back to here for a second
in fact I'm just gonna get this hat away
eyes down here so by the way in case
you're wondering hoc exam calculators
all that fun stuff okay let's have a
look down here do you remember when we
started with this original regular
cosine function okay and then we said Oh
what if I slap a two at the front here
what effect did that have on our period
yeah we / - did you see that right so we
divided by two two player became prime
so far so good I don't actually want to
divide by two though I'm for starters I
don't want the PI to be there the PI is
in there all of the ones that I've just
done right so if I want to divide by PI
instead of by two I shouldn't write cos
2x I should write cos PI X right that's
going to mean when you take the period
from two pi which is where you start
that's your starting point
I should divide by PI so what's the
period gonna be for this guy this is
gonna be you started at 2 pi seconds you
divided by PI 2 pi and PI that's just 2
seconds right 2 seconds now this is good
this is progress right I've got all that
gross pi Radian stuff out of the way but
I need to do one more thing right cuz
this is still way too fast we already
know how to slow things down how do I
get from 2 seconds to 90 seconds what do
I do
I should divide by 45 okay we saw the
division here slows things down so
that's what I'm gonna do I'm gonna take
that PI X which I want I want the PI
there right and then I'm going to divide
by 45 okay now if you're desmos there
what I want you to do is two things
number one go ahead and change this our
X in here so I should get this out the
way for you change that X to be PI X on
45 go ahead and put that in fun fact if
you just type in the letters P and I
you'll get you'll get that which is kind
of handy it's like oh thanks thanks for
desmos it /
25 okay does this look good what do you
think you can check it it's bang on by
the way here's a little um here's a
little handy secret for you go out to
the wrench icon over here into the
settings and you can change your scale
to be whatever you want the thing that I
suggest is on the horizontal axis which
is here there's x-axis right there you
can change the step that's how often it
marks in the line where one eighty and
ninety seconds so I'm gonna put that as
the step being 33 zero and you can see
have a look 30 60 90 and bang on that's
where the top of my motion is which is
where I started so one full cycle so far
so good okay now we just have one last
thing one last thing when you get on to
a ferris wheel right at time zero when
you board do you board the first wheel
at the top of the ferris wheel if you're
like man in parachuting down possibly
but usually not right so I actually want
this to start down the bottom how do I
take the top and put it down the bottom
I make it negative what do I make
negative I kind of take the whole thing
and I make it negative right so at the
front of 35 go it go over there and slap
a minus sign in there okay how does this
look what do you reckon are you happy
with that I'm pretty pleased with that
this looks real good yeah you start down
at a time zero how high you above the
ground you're at two right because
that's where the loading point is then
you get on it goes around and after 90
seconds you're back to the start if you
need to get off and so on so far so good
okay so well done you've just created
the motor I know that took a lot of
thought that's why we use technology to
help us can I get a show of hands who
has already gotten onto campus canvas
and downloaded the Fitzpatrick exercise
it's talk point for that I think is
laser scanned in has anyone got it ok if
you haven't done it do it now because
this is question one you just created
the model for question one and I'm gonna
walk you through the rest of the
questions so alright so what you should
see
I think I've got a screenshot here
someone is this what you can see this
should be question one except the scan
should look better than this okay all
right so what I want you to do is with
this
I think especially because your des mots
also in front of you the first question
says sketch now you pretty much have
that graph in front of you but there's
one difference you might notice read it
with me it says sketch the graph of H of
T let me just highlight that for a
second what does that mean H of T what
is that
it's that's height that's the function
and the thing you're inputting the
variable is T for time right so that's
why we have an H axis and a time axis I
should just make that look a little more
like axes all right
it says sketch that for a three minute
period so when we put this into desmos
we put no restrictions on it it just
kind of went yeah so three minutes is
180 seconds so you're gonna have to go
from 0 with a graph that you can see
right there you want the graph from 0
all the way over 90 seconds gets you to
one cycle and then 180 will get you to
two full cycles ok so go ahead and do
that have a go at a and then I'll come
around and have a check and see how
you're going B and C honestly you can do
on your own as well but I will do them
on the board once you how to go through
a on your own ok